if you really don't want to do much for
your lawn there's different grasses you
should pick that take less care if you
really want to invest a fair amount of
energy in your lawn then you pick
different grasses that will require a
little more mowing watering and
fertilizing so you have to set your
expectations and then recognize what
you're willing to do to get that long
the four main grass species that we have
Kentucky bluegrass perennial ryegrass
tall fescue and the fine fescues
Kentucky bluegrass is generally a higher
maintenance grass than some of the
others has a higher nitrogen requirement
and one of the disadvantages of Kentucky
bluegrass when you're seeding is that
it's very slow to germinate from seed
perennial ryegrass needs full Sun it
germinates quicker than any of the other
cool season grasses so for repairing a
bare spot perennial ryegrass if you're
in full Sun is a good choice this is the
one that's going to give you cover the
quickest tall fescue likes the Sun it
does have some moderate shade tolerance
one of the nice things about tall fescue
it is the most heat and drought tolerant
of our cool season grasses so if if you
don't ever plan to water your lawn or if
your lawn is in full Sun or perhaps you
have a sandy soil that doesn't retain
water you may want to consider tall
fescue if you've got moderate shade or
kind of filtered filtered shade in parts
of your lawn where you want to have
grass fine fescues would be the the
grass to try make sure to read the label
a lot of the cheap seed mixes will
include a big proportion sometimes
ninety percent of annual rye grass
rather than perennial make sure that
you've got perennial ryegrass and not
annual rye grass the other thing avoid
mixes where the variety is not stated
the work that you need to put into it to
see an area is the same whether you use
a good mix or a bad mix so take the time
and read the label and make sure that
you're getting the best value for your
dollar